let me ask you boost what the first time
you met John your first conversation
about how that movie would be shaped
well I've read the script and it was
like Stephanie was totally blown away I
think I cried too it's really powerful
then I met with Steve and John down at
43rd and Degnan or wherever is that what
they all cut it
was it a Carolyn Carolyn says open up a
little to the editor steam downer had
this little shack where she had all
different movies would be cut and
everything and stuff there and it's just
it was a nice little home each other I
think that we had to cut the Big Chill
there and stuff rather pictures there
and we just cut it there on film and
also when we met I mean we were all
three of us really just kind of really
bonded we loved everything from Coppola
setting you know taxi drivers our
favorite film crews set Kurosawa John
left 400 blows one of my favorite films
we just had a deep and we all really
connected strongly one of the things
that still sticks out the film just
every boat talking about this is a sound
mix either hearing helicopters Romans or
or Rick and Dennis ball nasi was the
mixer also hear you sound of kids
throughout the encountered a warm manner
now pop the bass yeah well you hear kids
all the time the movie even when they're
not on screen you hear kids are the
voices of children now what's up with
that cool thing about this picture is
see I had to take sound twice at USC
didn't do too well ticket I always tell
this story I took it as a sophomore and
there's two sections there's sound and
camera I did good in the camera part but
the sound part they teach you about the
cyclic Rousseff's of sound and rumor
preparation time and how fast sound
travels in air and in water and and then
and different things and to teach about
songs a thousand in physics and I was
like why hell I need to notice to make
more yes right so I kind of tanked my my
sophomore year in that sector so I
brought my agreed now so the second
semester of my senior year I had to take
that class over again and that was a
spring and then going into the summer we
were in pre-production boys in the hood
so I was thinking I'd take it twice you
know it was idiot at the time you know
about what the sounds of the
neighborhood were and so when you hear
the helicopters hear the distant gunfire
you hear the children
here people you know talking and having
full conversations in the background we
we created a sound design that actually
was followed by every other urban movie
for the next twenty some years I never
saw the helicopters yeah yeah however
listen any every movie it's they try to
sound like boys on the hood well think
of each of the Kleist
the class twice is all I have to say
about that yes but Steve with the ideas
dremen did a great job on them oh he did
it really did it yeah you know what yeah
he played was like whoa they've
determined Brothers were like amazing I
didn't even know that you and I didn't
have to go to a foley I went to the
Foley I went to every every little
aspect of that the the post-production
mix cuz a PO professional process cuz I
was I don't know I'm showing up we had
Tata yo they got the great posters on
the wall back then I was like whoa okay
yeah it was it was a wonderful thing for
me because at that time it was a really
confirms and there were a few other
directors that had things up but what
was really special to me was John it was
a very young director at that time
obviously but he was really intuitive
with the music and I I have to have to
tell you this one thing I remember when
we were spotting the film I think John
it screened it for me and he said he sat
next to me and he said uh you know I
want to use violins and orchestra in
this in this movie because I wanted to
be special and I wanted to last forever
and that and that was a very beautiful
thing because you know when I was
younger I used to see a lot of films and
and it was always wah-wah pedals if
somebody was making love it was Wacka
Wacka Wacka Wacka he's running down the
street Wacka Wacka someone's Phil
Pressey very little guitars like how you
talk basis like this like very little
time yeah and and and John said John
said no guitar in the movie whatsoever
and I told him I put it in one place
he still hasn't told me where it is in
there one place you know but it was it
was beautiful because it was
GameChanger for me it was nice to see
music you know with real emotion because
you know as actors you know these guys
have this was very emotional and so I
got I had the opportunity to do that so
I really wanted to thank John for giving
me the opportunity to be able to use my
skills so I just want to add Stanley's
music really kicked it up a notch um oh
yes yes yes we did
who we didn't have this music I know
once the music was in it just came alive